네 여러분들 영끌족이라는 말이
있습니다 어 영끌족이란 영혼까지
끌어모아서 부동산을 투자한다는 말을
줄여서 얘기한 건데 그리고 최근에
무피 투자도 되게 유행하고 있어요
그러니까 이제 돈을 안 들이고 부동산
투자를 하는 어 그런 투자가 되게
유행하고 있습니다 그런 연글 투자
그리고 무피 투자가 얼마나 위험한지
제가 오늘 세 가지로 좀 설명을
드리도록 하겠습니다 연글 투자에 되게
여러 가지 방법이 있는데 뭐 무피
투자 있어요 돈을 아예 안 들이고
하는 투자도 있고 그리고 이제 갭투자
매매가 전세가 계 차이가 없어서
현금이 많이 안 들어가는 그런 투자를
많이 하는데 정말 최악의 투자는
뭐냐면 다가구 주택이 뭐 예를 들어서
10억이다라고 하면 보증금이 한 7
8억 되는 거를 뭐 현금 뭐 2억 뭐
3억 이렇게 해가지고 사는 경우도
있거든요 근데 이게 문제가 뭐냐면
나중에 이제 전세 만기가 됐을 때
보증금을 돌려 줘야 될 돈이 있어야
되거든요 그리고 여러분들이 모르시는
것 중에 하나가 새로 임차인을 구하면
되지 뭐 이런 생각을 하시는데 새로
임차인을 구할 수가 없어요 왜냐하면
보증금이 워낙 비율이 높으니까 그리고
이제 전세자금 대출 안 나옵니다
이렇게 터지시는 분들을 되게 많이
봤어요 그냥 진짜 현금 얼마 안
들어가고 건물주 될 수 있다라고 해서
매입을 했는데 나중에 임차인이 만기
되고 나서 줄 돈도 없고 갑자기 경매
들어가고 뭐 이런 경우를 워낙 많이
받기 때문에 여러분들이 그냥 돈이 안
들어가고 갭 투자로 해 가지고 1
2억 아니면 2 3억으로 살 수
있다라는 말이 현혹돼서는 경우가 있기
때문에 이렇게 풀 대출로 만약에
건물을 매입한다고 했을 때 임차인이
중간에 나갈 수도 있거든요 근데 이제
대부분 다 100% 만실을 생각해요
만시 릴 때 뭐 임대료가 어느 정도
나오겠지 이렇게 생각을 하는데 정말
여러분들이 진짜 보수적으로 봐야
됩니다 진짜 많이 차도 한 7 80%
아니면 진짜 반이 비어 있더라도
내가이자 감당이 될지를 판단하고
투자를 해야 되는데 항상 꽉 차 있을
때를 생각을 해요 그래서 예를 들어서
뭐 대출 이자가 뭐 500만 원이다
했을 때 꽉 찼을 때 500만 원
나오니까 감당이 될거다 이렇게 생각을
하지만 그 와중에 공실도 되게 많이
생길 겁니다 그 나머지 동우는 내가
다 메꿔야 되거든요 그 심지어 이런
경우도 맞어요 투잡을 뛰시는 분들도
있어요 그니까이 이자를 내기 위해서
그리고 어떤 경우도 있냐면 대출을
제가 만약에 받았을 때 뭐 변동
금리로 받았다 아니면 이제 만기가
지났다고 했을 때 신용 상태가 좋지
않다라고 하면 대출 금리가 진짜 엄청
올라갑니다 일부는 또 상환하라고 할
수도 있거든요 갑자기 돈이 없는데 뭐
1 2억을 갑자기 상환하라고 상한을
할 수가 없거든요 연장이 안 되는
경우도 있고 그래서 여러분들이 항상
대출을 받을 때는 되게 신중하게
받으셔야 되고 제가 뭐 일전 영상에도
말씀드렸지만 제일 안전한 수준은 저는
한 30에서 50% 정도라고 생각을
해요 그리고 그 이상은 내가 대출이자
감당이 가능할지를 보고 투자를 해야
됩니다 근데 대부분의 투자자분들은
일단은 현금을 적게 드리고 건물주만
되면 다 돈 버다 생각을 해요 근데
그게 아니라 대출을 받을 때는 굉장히
신중하게 받아야 되고 그리고 100%
만실일 경우는 없습니다 진짜 많이
찼을 때는 7 80% 차 있고 한
50% 정도 차 있을 때 내가이자
감당이 될지를 봐야 돼요 나중에
만기가 돼서 금리가 올라갔을 때도
내가 감당이 될지를 봐야 됩니다이
모든 전개가 부동산 가격이 다
오른다고 생각 하는데 만약에 뭐
작년처럼 부동산 가격이 내려갈 때
그때 만약에 지금 이렇게 고금리에
부동산 가격이 내려가는 상황이라면
정말 힘든 경우도 많거든요 그래서
항상 대출을 받아서 투자를 할 때는
되게 신중하셔야 되고 그리고 보증금
비율이 높은 갭투자 이런 것도 할
때도 내가 이렇게 보증금을 내 줄
돈이 있는지까지도 충분히 검토한
다음에 투자를 해야 되고 그 모든
거의 전제는 건물주가 된다라고 해서
다 성공한 거는 아니기 때문에 일단은
기본적으로 부동산 가치가 있는 그런
부동산을 투자한다는게 일단 첫
번째입니다 돈 없이 투자를 할 수
있다 그거보다는 무조건 본질로 좀
돌아가서 진짜 좋은 부동산을 산다라는
가정하에 투자를 하는 것이 이런
실패확률을 좀 줄일 수 있지 않을까
어 연글 투자를 예방하기에 위한
방법은 첫 번째로 부동산 본질을
파악하자 무조건 건물주 돼서 뭐 돈을
벌 수 있다 그게 아니라이 부동산이
어디 위치해 있고 어떤 부동산이고
나중에 시장에 내놨을 때 팔릴 수
있는지를 가장 먼저 파악하는게
중요하고 그 두 번 째로 최악의
경우를 생각하자 건물이 항상 풀로
차이는게 아니라 비어 있을 수 있다
생각하고 진짜 건물이 다 비어 있어도
진짜 1년 2년 그 이상은이자 감당이
될 수 있다 뭐 이렇게까지 생각을
해야 되고 그리고 세 번째로 변수의
상황이 생겨요 그러니까 이제 내가
연글 투자 했다라고 해도 생각지
못했던 비용이 발생되거나 아니면 이제
이자가 감장이 올라가거나 이런
이슈들이 생기기 때문에 진짜 내가
탈탈 털어서 만약에 부동산 투자를
하고 했을 때 특히 빌딩 같은
경우에는 예상치 못했던 비용들이 많이
발생되거나 이런 예비비가 내가 가지고
있을 수 있는지 내가 부담이
가능한지를 어 체크해 보고 투자를
하는게 이런 연글 투자 예방을 할 수
있다라고 생각합니다 그리고 저희
구독자분들은 아마 제가 취미 마르도록
제가 말씀을 드렸기 때문에 어 이런
연글 투자에 뭔가 좀 진짜 현혹되지
마시고 좀 판단을 잘못해서 좀 이렇게
잘못된 이런 투자를 안 하셨으면
좋겠습니다 그리고 요즘에 막 SNS
뭐 유튜브라는 이런 자극적인 얘기들을
많이 하는데 그런게 사실 저희 좋은
물건 나오면 사실 홍보 안 하거든요
그냥 이제 고객 내에서 이렇게 하는
경우가 되게 많습니다 어떻게 보면 다
미끼 매물이에요 안 팔리는 매물이라
그지 안 좋은 매물들을 뭔가 미끼
매물로 물어서 사람들을 많이 모아서
공투 하게 되거나 공투 절대 하지
마세요 공투 문제가 100%
발생됩니다 김승호 회장님이 했던
얘기가 아직도 생각나는데 남의 돈을
내 돈보다 소중하게 생각하면 공투
해라 어 돈의 속성의 책에 있었던데
정말 공투 여러분 절대 하지 마세요
분쟁이 무조건 생깁니다 차라리 빌딩을
안 사는게 낫습니다 차 안 사는 한이
있더라도 단독으로 하시는게 가장
좋습니다 그래서 여러분들이 아마 공투
최근에 많더라고요 공투 대해서도
영상이 필요하다라고 하면 댓글 남겨
주시면 제가 한번 준비도 해
보겠습니다 저는 공투 직접 해
봤거든요 그래서 뭔가 안 좋은 점
한번 제가 리스트업 해 가지고 한번
영상을 좀 준비해 보도록 하겠습니다
오늘 영상은 여기까지
[음악]
하겠습니다 h